you'll probably disagree
about this question but what is your
biggest would you say disagreement
about either something uh profound and
very important or something completely
not important at all
i don't think we have any disagreements
at all ah i'm not sure that's true
we walked into that one didn't we yeah
so so one thing that you sometimes
mention
is that and we did this one on air too
as it were
whether or not machine learning is
computational statistics
it's not but it is well it's not and in
particular
and more importantly it is not just
computational statistics
so what's missing in the picture what's
all the rest of it
what's missing that which is missing oh
because well you can't be wrong now well
it's not just the statistics he doesn't
even believe this
we've had this conversation before if it
were just the statistics then
we would be happy with where we are but
it's not just the statistics that's why
it's computational statistics or if it
were just the computation i agree that
machine learning is not just statistics
it is not just we can agree on that nor
is it just computational statistics it's
computational statistics it is
computational what is the computational
and computational statistics
does this take us into the realm of
computing it does but i think
perhaps the way i can get him to admit
that uh he's wrong
is that it's about rules it's about
rules it's about symbols it's about all
these other things
the statistics is not about rules i'm
going to say statistics is about rules
but it's not just the statistics right
it's not just a random variable that you
choose and you have a probability i
think you have a narrow view of
statistics okay well then
what would be the broad view of
statistics that would still allow it to
be statistics and not say
history uh that would make computational
statistics okay
well okay so i i had my first sort of
research mentor
a guy named tom landauer taught me to do
some statistics
right sure and and i was annoyed all the
time because the statistics would say
that what i was doing was not
statistically significant
and i was like but but but and
basically what he said to me is
statistics is how you're going to keep
from lying to yourself
which i thought was really deep it is a
way
to keep yourself honest in a particular
way i agree with that yeah and so you're
trying to find
rules i'm just kind of bringing back to
rules
wait wait wait could you possibly try to
define
rules even regular statisticians
non-computational statisticians
do spend some of their time evaluating
rules right applying statistics to try
to understand is this you know is this
does this rule capture this does this
not capture
i mean like hypothesis testing kind of
or like confidence intervals like
like have like more like hypothesis like
i feel like the word statistic literally
means like a summary
like a number that summarizes other
numbers right but i think the field of
statistics actually applies that idea
to things like rules to understand
whether or not a rule is
valid so software engineering statistics
no programming languages statistics no
because i think there's a very it's
useful to think about a lot of what ai
and machine learning is or certainly
should be
as software engineering uh as
programming languages
just if to put it in language that you
might understand
the hyperparameters beyond the problem
the hyperparameters has too many
syllables for me to understand
the hyperparameters of uh that's better
that goes around it right it's the
decisions you
choose to make it's the metrics you
choose to use it's the loss
you want to say the practice of machine
learning is different than the practice
of statistics like the things you have
to worry about and how you worry about
them are different
therefore they're different right at a
very little i mean at the very least
it's that that much is true it doesn't
mean that statistics computational or
otherwise aren't important
i think they are i mean i do a lot of
that for example
but i think it goes beyond that i think
that we could think about game theory in
terms of statistics but i don't think
it's very
as useful to do i mean the way i would
think about it or a way i would think
about it is
this way chemistry is just physics
but i don't think it's as useful to
think about chemistry as being just
physics it's useful to think about
it as chemistry the level of abstraction
really matters here so i think it is
there are contexts in which it is useful
yeah think of it that way right now so
finding that connection is actually
helpful and i think that's when i when i
emphasize the computational statistics
thing i think
i think i want to befriend statistics
and not absorb them
you